[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter
theory in today's video we're going to
be discussing
voldemort nagini and their relationship
more specifically i'm going to be
providing you with one of my own
theories
which suggests that voldemort's entire
relationship with nagini
was formed on a lie now if you're
familiar with the nagini from the time
period where the harry potter books
films take place
then you'll surely know that nagini was
always glued to voldemort's side
voldemort and nagini were rarely apart
and nagini is actually introduced
fairly early on in the series in the gob
to fire
which is described as eating the body of
muggle frank bryce
and while it's easy to think of nagini
when you think of voldemort
and vice versa there was actually a time
not so long ago
that the pair had never been introduced
that's right
voldemort didn't have his trusty
serpentine companion
this is something that's truly hard to
imagine particularly as she is
constantly glued to his side after her
introduction
sticking by him through thick and thin
she was
even one of voldemort's horcruxes the
horcrux he made
after the murder of perth jorkins seems
like the pair
are pretty close right but wait a second
didn't nagini only meet voldemort after
becoming a snake
that's right as first revealed in
fantastic beasts
nakini was once a woman a maledictus to
be exact
meaning that she carried with her a
horrible curse
somewhere in nagini's bloodline the
maledictus curse was present
a dark curse that is passed on through
generations of family members
and is transferred from mother to
daughter because of this
nakini was born a female maledictus
a maledictus suffers from blood
maladiction
a type of curse that causes the sufferer
to slowly transform into an animal
over the course of their life for nagini
this animal happened to be a snake
meaning she became more snake and less
human
each day for a few years the melodictus
will generally possess the ability to
transform
at will but that slips over time
eventually
they lose the ability to transform all
together
trapping them in whatever their
maledictus form is forever
when we see voldemort with nagini their
relationship had already been
established
we also know that nagini had been stuck
in a snake form
from the time that they first met before
meeting voldemort and before
transforming
permanently nagini lived an awful life
where she was labelled a freak
and put on display by the circus arcanus
it wasn't until credence came along that
she finally escaped
now after this happened there's a bit of
a gray area
we're currently in the midst of the
fantastic beasts series
and we don't yet know what happens to
nagini
in the short term we only know that
eventually
she meets voldemort we don't know the
exact date but
most speculate that voldemort and nagini
met in the forest of albania
sometime in the 1980s at this stage
nakini was fully subjected to her curse
trapped in her snake form
and voldemort was hiding in his
disembodied state after being defeated
by the potters we don't know exactly how
their first meeting went
but we do know that voldemort speaks
parcel tongue thanks to his heritage
so it's likely that voldemort was one of
the first humans to
communicate with nagini for a very long
time
after she turned into a snake for the
last time she would have lost her
ability to communicate with other humans
we don't know how exactly voldemort
deduced that nagini was a maledictus
but i imagine she simply told him at
this stage
both of them were lost souls however
they did eventually partner up
and nagini became instrumental in
voldemort's resurgence
nagini had nowhere to go and voldemort
didn't know what his next move was
so it only makes sense that they would
buddy up however one thing that's
overlooked here
is that nagini though she lived quite a
traumatic life
was actually a pretty decent person
before becoming the menacing snake we
know from the films
this led to me asking the question why
did nagini
serve the dark lord voldemort she was a
good person before
right here's where my theory comes in i
think that
the only way that nagini could have been
pushed to do the dark things that
voldemort asked of her
would be a voldemort had something over
her i think that
to gain the guinea's allegiance and
trust he promised that one day
he would transform her back into a woman
but i don't think that voldemort could
actually do it
he made a false promise voldemort was a
powerful dark wizard
and he could perform a lot of magic so i
imagined
it would have been easy to convince a
desperate nagini to serve him
dangling the prospect of becoming a
woman again
of course after years of service imagine
nagini did become a bit evil
herself what do you guys think of this
theory let me know
in the comment section below until next
time it does not do to dwell on dreams
forget to live
[Music]
you